[Música]
boa tarde eu quero começar pedindo que
vocês experimentem visualizar a primeira
imagem que aparece na mente de vocês eu
falo de um homem ganancioso tenta
visualizar um homem ganancioso
agora eu vou tentar ver se eu adivinho a
imagem mais ou menos a imagem que vocês
visualizaram foi alguma coisa tipo assim
talvez não talvez uma coisa um pouco
mais ostentação tipo isso aqui
ou talvez algo mais sexy tipo isto
talvez uma coisa mais lúdica mais
conhecida tipo nosso querido estado
burns
pois é essas foram imagens que eu
encontrei ao pesquisar sobre o termo
ganância na internet e elas são muito
compatíveis à percepção que eu também
tinha esse termo é eu aprendi sobre a
ganância mais ou menos o que vocês
provavelmente também aprenderam que
querer mais e desejar mais coisas era
uma coisa egoísta era mau caratismo era
falta de empatia que você olhar para um
mundo tão ruim tão cheio de dor e de
tristeza e desejar abundância conforto
era egoísmo e que você ser ganancioso
era basicamente sua culpa todos os males
da humanidade
mas vocês sabiam que originalmente a
palavra ganância vem do termo castelhano
gana que significa desejo e vontade
o verbo ngana do castelhano significa só
vencer conquistar ganhar só isso nada de
pisar em ninguém nada de queimar
dinheiro no charuto nada do tipo
é eu vou de compartilhar com vocês hoje
um pouquinho da minha história e vou
explicar para vocês o quanto mudar
profundamente a minha percepção sobre o
termo ganância foi transformador
libertador no meu caminho em busca da
minha felicidade
eu vou deixar esse sentido
e pra gente lembrar que sempre fala em
ganância eu tô falando dessas aqui eu
comecei a trabalhar os quatro anos de
idade como atriz e eu trabalhei durante
toda minha infância minha adolescência e
juventude
mas mesmo trabalhando bastante e eu
nunca me senti bem em gastar meu
dinheiro em comprar coisas pra mim eu
sempre me senti muito mal com isso eu me
sentia como se fosse injusto que eu
pudesse comprar coisas talvez vocês
supérfluas e outras pessoas não pudessem
comprar nem comida nem água é eu ganhava
bem era bem remunerado mas não era feliz
naquele trabalho e eu aos poucos fui me
aproximando da psicologia e fui
percebendo que realmente não ver sentido
naquele trabalho não admirava aquela
função e o que eu queria fazer da minha
vida era trabalhar desenvolvendo pessoas
ajudando pessoas a se tornarem as
melhores versões que elas pudessem ser
de si mesmos e eu decidi trocar de
carreira
migrei seguir esse meu chamado interno
só que eu percebi que mesmo trabalhando
em algo que eu amava e que houve um
sentido enorme eu continuava não me
sentindo à vontade em ganhar dinheiro eu
falei puxa vida
se antes eu trabalhava em algo que eu
não via muito sentido e eu não me sentia
bem ao receber o dinheiro hoje eu
trabalho em algo que eu acho que tem uma
importância enorme para o mundo eu
continuo me sentindo bem receber alguma
coisa a ver comigo com a minha relação
com o dinheiro com o meu merecimento
eu comecei a investigar quem eu era o
que eu queria entrar naquela fase de
crise existencial e eu encontrei o meu
propósito de vida a minha missão o que
fazer sentido para mim eu queria ajudar
o maior número possível de pessoas a se
tornarem a melhor pessoa que elas
poderiam ser eu queria alcançar não só
aquelas pessoas que viriam até o meu
consultório pessoas que já tinham
abertura para um processo terapêutico eu
queria pessoas que tinham preconceito
que achavam isso besteira queixavam-se
bobagem eu queria quebrar essas
barreiras
eu queria mostrar que o autoconhecimento
não precisa ser chato e aí me dei conta
de uma coisa eu era gananciosa
eu estava visualizando sendo ouvida
pelas pessoas
eu estava visualizando dando cursos
fazendo cursos fora dando palestras eu
falei meu deus eu estou ansioso estou
querendo coisas grandes eu não quero só
o necessário não só coisas simples
eu quero mais eu quero usar a minha
visibilidade
só que eu tinha aprendido que pessoas
gananciosas eram pessoas mais então eu
era uma pessoa maravilhosa que nunca me
vi como uma pessoa má
esse maniqueísmo não estava fazendo
sentido pra mim então foi quando eu
comecei a decidir estudar a riqueza
abundância a ação humana como se dão as
trocas entre os indivíduos como cidão
enfim a distribuição de recursos no
mundo e eu percebi algo que pra mim foi
muito transformador
a ganância está presente na humanidade
desde sempre e foi ela que nos trouxe
até aqui
o homem tem um desejo inerente por mais
por algo maior por realizar coisas que
ultrapassem o limite físico a finitude
nosso corpo ele quer deixar legado ele
quer fazer algo a mais ele quer agregar
um sentido para a vida dele victor
franco afirma que o equilíbrio suposto
equilíbrio que nós buscamos na verdade
ele está justamente nesse desequilíbrio
nessa tensão que se estabelece entre o
homem e os sentido entre o ser ea sua
busca e terra
isso é a ganância e ela não tem nada de
mal muito pelo contrário
quando nós temos a nossa o nosso direito
a ganância negada ou cerceado de alguma
forma quando nós aprendemos que a
ganância o mal da humanidade e é o
grande mal é imoralidade
o mal de todos os males nós acabamos
fazendo o que nós pegamos os nossos
desejos mais profundos e guardamos numa
caixinha
nós negamos isso e pior nós
transformamos esse desejo sem rancor em
frustração em vitimização e uma sensação
de que nós não somos mais os
protagonistas da nossa vida
somos vítimas passivas nós não podemos
permitir que isso aconteça
o homem precisa de liberdade para
construir para desejar e para fazer o
que for necessário para chegar a esse
lugar que lhe desejo eu fui percebendo
ao longo desse processo que mesmo que eu
quisesse ter uma vida puramente 100%
dedicada à filantropia caridade eu
precisaria de recursos para poder acabar
com a fome no mundo ascende no mundo com
as doenças tudo isso necessita de
recursos e para conquistar esses
recursos
a denúncia é necessária absolutamente
necessária e olha se a gente for olhar
para esse sentido
mesmo que você diga eu não sou
ganancioso eu só quero uma casinha
simples para viver com os animaizinhos e
plantar tomates
você também tem um desejo também é um
desejo e esse desejo deve ser valorizado
e respeitado tanto quanto quem deseja
comprar uma lancha e seu reitor camarote
a gente precisa respeitar isso a
ganância precisa ser desculpa utilizada
era só passa a ser um problema quando
ela vem acompanhada da falta de ética da
falta de moralidade da falta de caráter
então ela não é um problema por si só
pelo contrário foi ela que mobilizou e
fez com que a humanidade caminhasse o
comércio ele é motivado pela ganância
como nos diz adam o sme ele nos explica
que não é da benevolência do padeiro que
nós esperamos nosso pãozinho é dado o
interesse que ele tem sobre as próprias
necessidades bem e é muito importante
que a gente entenda que a humanidade ela
tem esse desejo e que a gente precisa
respeitar essa essa necessidade humana
a paula que faz ser hoje esteve aqui
compartilhando com a gente a linda
história que ela passou
e claro foi uma história de dor mas que
de superação
paula passou anos mergulhada em um
profundo silêncio e graças à tecnologia
graças ao implante coclear ela pode
voltar a ouvir assim como marta
acho o implante coclear só se tornou
possível quando a tecnologia permitiu
que as pecinhas ficassem muito
pequenininhas para incluir já pensaram
cuja ansioso foi o primeiro homem que
disse vou inventar um aparelho para
colocar na cabeça dos surdos para que
eles possam voltar a ouvir na fascinante
ele foi muito ganancioso e eu pergunto
será que ele lá no fundo queria ganhar
dinheiro ou será que ele lá no fundo
estava puramente interessado no bem dos
surdos que estavam sem ouvir ou será que
as duas coisas eu não sei eu só sei que
hoje a paula esteve aqui conversando com
a gente e ela está aqui ouvindo minha
voz
graças a estes homens nós não podemos
romantizar o primitivismo mano victor
franco afirma e mais uma vez eu concordo
com ele que o homem ele só consegue se
realizar plenamente quando ele consegue
encontrar qual é sua missão no mundo e
começa a caminhar pra colocar essa
missão de verdade concreta para realizar
esse objetivo
é isso que é a maior potência humana
esse agente mega isso agente nega o
nosso maior poder que é avaliar o
contexto em que a gente se encontra
visualizar uma solução e um futuro da
maneira como a gente deseja e caminhar
de forma ética de forma civilizada para
colocar esse sonho no mundo real
é muito importante a gente aceitar e
acolher e assumir a nossa ganância
somos gananciosos sim isso é muito
importante para a humanidade
na minha prática clínica muitas vezes eu
encontro frases como a humanidade é
terrível é um vírus no planeta é o homem
deu errado tem que explodir tudo começar
de novo eu tenho vergonha de fazer parte
do ser humano algumas tirinhas como
essas são muito encontradas na internet
né
o mundo é uma coisa horrível deus me
livre estar presente nesse lugar
como uma pessoa que enxerga a humanidade
dessa forma vai conseguir se apropriar
de tudo
os seus recursos e se tornar uma pessoa
fantástica
se ela abomina a espécie a qual ela
pertence
relaxa o mundo um lugar horrível e se
ela acredita que é justamente essa
sensação de eu quero ser mais eu sou
ganancioso e eu desejo mais que faz com
que o mundo seja esse lugar tão horrível
ela não vai
e aliás essa visão de que o mundo é um
lugar horrível muitas palestras do ted
já falaram sobre isso mas eu faço
questão de falar de novo porque é muito
importante o mundo não é um lugar tão
horrível quanto vocês imaginam
nós somos humanos nosso cérebro tem um
dispositivo de procura de sobrevivência
de preservação da espécie então isso é
natural
é natural que nós entendamos a olhar
mais para o que não está funcionando bem
porque é perigoso do que o que está
funcionando bem então tudo bem é
compreensível mas quando a gente
acredita que o mundo é um lugar tão
tenebroso e que a culpa de sua ganância
nós pegamos a nossa ganância escondemos
de nós mesmos e isso vai paralisando o
mundo já que não é o mundo não é um
lugar tão horrível assim vamos avaliar
alguns dados muito simples basicamente a
expectativa de vida subiu de 30 para
mais de 70 anos em menos de um século o
número de mortes de crianças anualmente
caiu de mais de 20 milhões para menos de
8 milhões em menos de 60 anos
mas ahadi camus doenças a nossa jornada
de trabalho era mais de 65 horas
semanais e hoje ela está em basicamente
o mundo está melhorando a humanidade
está aos poucos aprendendo a usar os
recursos que têm
eu sei que existem problemas sim muitos
eu concordo mas será que a solução é
regredir estagna a gente tem que se
apropriar da nossa ganância e usá-la de
forma ética
quanto mais nós os gananciosos éticos
que estão dispostos a correr atrás dos
seus sonhos sem pisar em ninguém e sem
volta de lado a moralidade
quanto mais nós abandonamos o mundo
quanto mais nós damos de mão nós nos
entregamos de bandeja todos os recursos
e todo o universo
essas pessoas que são gananciosas e que
não tem ética
nós precisamos nos apropriar disso e
construir o nosso caminho é fazer tudo
que nós podemos para conquistar o que
desejamos sabendo que nós não só não
estamos fazendo mal a ninguém como mais
do que isso estamos ajudando a roda do
mundo a girar
estamos fazendo bem aos próximos rock eu
sei a palavra ganância já foi denegrida
não dá mais pra gente resgatá lá mas eu
vou propor um outro verbo existe uma
palavra em inglês que designa a pessoa
que pensa grande que deseja coisas
grandes que é um mês de muitas coisas
mas que não quer pisar em ninguém para
chegar um desejo esse verbo se chama
trois
em português ele é prosperar eu quero
pra esperar eu quero um futuro cheio de
abundância pra mim e pra minha família
eu quero conseguir lutar por tudo o que
eu desejo por todos os meus objetivos
eu quero conquistar estabilidade
financeira eu quero conquistar conforto
e abundância para a minha família eu
quero poder passar muito mais tempo com
os meus filhos e para isso é preciso de
estabilidade financeira familiar
profissional eu quero ajudar pessoas que
não tenham recursos a se desenvolverem
como pessoas se desenvolverem como
profissionais
esses são os meus objetivos eles são
compatíveis aos meus valores e as coisas
são importantes pra mim e eu vou
precisar de recursos para fazer isso
tudo e eu estou disposta a conquistá los
sem pisar em ninguém
sem fazer nada de errado pra ninguém e
sem me sentir culpada por estar
almejando coisas eu quero prosperar e
ajudar pessoas a prosperarem porque eu
acredito verdadeiramente que essa é a
melhor forma de fazer o mundo prosperar
eu quero saber se vocês querem entrar
nessa jornada comigo vamos libertar do
nosso preconceito com a palavra ganância
e vamos aceitar a prosperidade nas
nossas vidas
boa noite
[Aplausos]